right good evening
everyone welcome members welcome
visitors thank you so much sorry I was
uh stuck in the traffic lights between
here and hawkley and there are several
so I apologize for being late
um item one I need to read the emergency
evacuation
announcements there are no planned fire
drills so if the alarm activates please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
via your nearest
exit please use either the fire exit
through the main doors of the hall or
the fire exit in the store room adjacent
to the
stage the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance to
the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff please note the meeting
will be live streamed please switch off
all mobile phones and turn them to or
turn them to
silent members to remind you if you're
intending to speak please turn on the um
the microphones otherwise you won't be
captured on live
stream item one apologies for
absence there are none all members are
attending non-members
attending coun we got councelor
FD councelor
mcferson thank you James and councelor
James Gooding you're spread out so it's
hard to see so thank you so much I shall
ask you to identify yourself eles
because he's too far away okay thank
you um item three the minutes of the
meeting held on the 21st of September
2023 members will all have a
copy I assume you've acquainted
yourselves with these beforehand so I'm
going to ask you if I can sign them as a
true and Fair View of the meeting held I
wasn't present of course I was absent
for that meeting agreed right is is
everyone is it unanimous thank you I'll
sign the
not item
four I need to receive any Declarations
of interest from
Members
um thank you councelor H just for the
record it's not a declaration of
Interest as such but it's just to make
it clear that I was on on the cost of
living working group um I attended
unfortunately only one meeting out of
the ones which took place but it's not
disclosable interest but I think it's
for transparency ought to be known yeah
thank you very
much councilor Williams yeah thank you
chairman um item seven non pecul
interest um I am a trustee of r that may
be involved with that thank
you okay you're going to remain for the
for the
item you your decision I'm happy for you
to do so thank you I won't vote but I
will remain thank you okay thank
you item
five questions on notice from
counselors as chairman I've looked at
the
questions and I am happy that there all
quite clear in terms of
context and as they're clear in terms of
context I'm going to ask you when it's
your turn to just read your
question in respect of question two from
councilor Belton in accordance with the
Constitution I shall be reading the
question so I can any find this
please I will take them in order
question
one agenda item
three minutes of the 21st of September
2023 minute line 182 CCTV in Ry High
Street question from councelor FY to the
lead me the executive lead member for
communities and
Health councelor Lisa
Newport councilor
thank you
chairman question is with recommendation
to being agreed at executive on the 21st
of September 2023 I would like to know
what consultation if any was sent to
rord Parish Council explaining the new
options and
recommendations of which recommendation
to States that the installation and
monitoring costs would be would all be
met by RDC in
perpetuity thank you Council refd if
you'd like to remain for the
answer Council and Mrs Newport thank you
thank you councelor FD when the
community safety fund was first
introduced Watford Parish Council
advised that they were not interested in
applying for a grant for installing
CCTV I am not aware of any formal
consultation or engagement that has been
undertaken with Rochford Parish
Council however they could still make an
approach to rord District Council if
they so
wished I'm loud enough without it I
know but uh the live stream wouldn't
have picked it up Council F you have a
supplementary
question yes thank you would the same
offer be extended to Rockford Parish
Council as the offer at the time was
different than what is in option a
recommendation
to thank you um I'll need to check with
the officers and I can get back to your
in writing with that thank you very
much thank you Council newort thank you
councelor
FD the second question I'm going to read
this question because councelor Belton
has has asked me to do so agenda item
seven on this agenda voluntary sector
grants cross party members panel
decision from councelor Mrs DS belon to
the executive lead member for leisure
and tourism and well-being
counselor Mrs
Gooding I'll read the question in June
of this
year I was one member of a group of
eight asked to participate in scoring
the voluntary Grant
applications whilst I am happy that this
decision has now come to the
executive I would like to ask the lead
member what has caused the four-month
delay in this report coming
forward I'll ask councilor Mrs goody to
respond to the question
[Music]
please I'd like to thank councelor
Belton for her question um she she is
correct in that the group met in June
this year to review and agree the
voluntary sector grants the successful
grants have been paid and there was a
delay in advising the unsuccessful
applicants as officers were looking for
alternative
funding in terms of the report report to
the executive unfortunately due to lack
of resources resulting in officers
oversight the report to the executive to
formally agree the grants has only been
made
tonight thank you
counc thank you council Mrs
goody now there will be no supplemental
question as Council Belton is not here
thank you thank you
the third
question thank you councilor mcferson
I'll wait for you to
arrive question from councelor mcperson
agenda item nine cost of living Co
payments from councelor Mrs J mcferson
to the executive lead member for Leisure
tourism and well-being councelor Mrs
goody thank you chairman um for openness
and
transparency I have to say it's a shame
that I am only coupled to ask the
question as chairman of overview and
scrutiny and know the work that the
committee put into this report my
question what is the executive's
rationale for deferring this report
again and thereby laying providing the
cost of living support to those members
of our communities who are really
struggling every day to make end's
meet thank you councelor
mcferson councel Mrs Gooding can you
give your response please yes I'd like
to than thank council at person for uh
your question um at the exec meeting on
the 21st of September members were
advised by officers that as yet no
criteria has been set and there was no
process in place to allocate grant
funding and if this was to be pursued it
would require some
thought on that basis a motion was
subsequently moved that the item be
deferred to the next meeting of the exec
however given the situation with staff
resources I believe we need to
prioritize this to meet residents needs
sooner rather than later and I will be
proposing a new motion when the item is
considered councilor Mrs person do you
have a supplemental
question thank you chairman um that was
a very pleasing answer however can I
just ask as the recommendation is for
deferral should the executive follow
that what is planned B is if key staff
absences
continue and bearing in mind the need
for support is now as we're now in
October how much longer will our
residents have to wait for this
support thank you councelor m
person councelor Mrs Gooding I have
escalated this situation up to the uh
senior um officers and I wonder if um
Steve if you're able to provide an
answer to that at this
time and if if you're not that's okay I
can come back to it
later so in terms of tonight obviously
we have to wait and see what members
decide in terms of the actual deferral
recommendation obviously that's that's
that's perative of the members here
tonight and we would have to consider
then if that's the case how we would go
forward in terms of um Staffing we are
currently looking at that and we were
looking at putting place um where we can
strengthen that Staffing so we're not in
a similar situation going
forward thank you does that conclude
your answer council Mrs
Gooding does it conclude your answer
thank you yes it does
thank you that concludes the questions
on notice from
Members I now move to item seven item
seven voluntary sector grants cross
party members panel
decision this item is reported for
information only there are no decision
to make but I'm going to ask ask
councelor Mrs Gooding as the lead member
to give context to the information
provided thank
you thank you chairman um the report
provides an update to members on the
work undertaken by officers to run the
voluntary sector Grant process and the
support given to members to review the
pertinent information from applications
and to contribute to the members panel
decision for 2023 to 2024 successful
voluntary sector grants within the
district I should point out that the
supporting papers in the report should
refer to the vsg process paper going to
the exec on the 12th of April 2023 not
the 13th of January
2023 if we could amend that
please all funding was allocated subject
to the applicants demonstr in how their
activities contribute to the health and
well-being board's outcome which align
with rdc's business plan priority which
is enabling
communities I would like to thank the
officers and the members of the Cross
party panel who kindly contributed to
the application process and can advise
that the payments have been made to the
successful applicants thank
you thank you coun is Gooding um it's an
information only item but it is open for
members of the executive committee to
ask further questions if if they wish if
you do if you wish to do so please
indicate councelor EES thank you chair
um it's really coming back to uh the
member question on notice obviously I
couldn't actually you can't come back to
that I'm sorry okay all right well in
that case then I would just like
reassurance that uh in future this is
going to come out in good
time that's it Council M Gooding can you
uh yes that Assurance yeah I would
expect that to happen in future
obviously we've already referred to the
fact that we had resources problems and
uh that was some of the issues thank
you councelor Mr Newport
thank you chairman um through you
chairman um I wonder if the lead member
knows or has the information to hand as
to whether any of the unsuccessful
applicants were able to obtain any grant
funding from alternative sources um with
the help of the officers that were
looking into that thank you thank you
tell M Gooding can you uh
assist I can't answer that at this
moment in time but I will come back to
you with the uh information uh as soon
as possible thank you for your question
can you circulate that to all members of
the executive please I will do thank
you are there any further questions
regarding this item seven which is for
information only there is no decision to
be made if there are no further
questions I will close the
item now move to to item eight item
eight is headed Christmas parking
suspension
councelor Mrs
Wilson um are you able to introduce this
report uh yes chair I certainly am thank
you okay good evening members um this
report sets out that car parking charges
in all car in all Council car parks are
suspended on The Saturdays during
December prior to Christmas and the
dates of the four Saturdays are listed
in the
report um I will come back to the
recommendation later I'd just like to
give you some background on this that
the council since
2009 has been offering free car parking
on Saturdays on the run up for uh the
Christmas
period
um the uh the report gives details um
also of the loss of income that that
will be to the council but this is
considered to be um a Goodwill option
not just to the businesses in this
District but to the residents
also a further option in this before
this report was written um did look up
the
Alternatives um available that we could
have to support local businesses um at
this time of year or indeed outside the
Christmas period
and this will be looked at um in the
coming year it was um considered that it
was too late it too late in the runup
for this year to do anything but I just
wanted to assure members that it's on
the agenda to look at for next
time so the
recommendation uh please I'm asking for
your support is that car parking charges
in all Council car parks are suspended
for the four Saturdays being the 2nd the
9th
the 16th and the 23rd of December
2023 thank you Council M Wilson are you
are you proposing I am sorry yes thank
you I've now asked whether there's a
seconder to that proposal I have I have
at least two um I was looking this way
so sadly um councelor EES I will accept
your seconding I will second that thank
you thank you I'd like to invite members
of the executive to um ask any further
questions and raise issues regarding the
report thank you Chris councelor Stanley
thank you thank you chairman um I wonder
if uh we should consider um taking off
the 23rd and using that for a New Year's
uh
Saturday um as this would encourage uh
footfall over the this period um as the
23rd is Christmas Eve sort of thing and
not you I'm not supposing that we will
find so many people out Christmas Eve at
parking but for New Years there will be
quite a considerable amount of vehicles
there that will obviously will use the
January the 1st as New Year's Day or New
Year's Eve so thing so I wonder have we
considered that is there a price that we
can look at in the way of
value i' I'd like to
ask P last I'd like to ask M Barnes who
who Penn the report um with Council
Wilson to um to consider giving advice
on that suggest
question so um thank you J as councelor
Wilson indicated um the report does
state that we will be looking at what we
can do as Alternatives in the new year
and Consulting with the local businesses
as well um the changes now late in from
from now lat day would result in
potential financial implications of
incurring cost to make additional
amendments to with our phone and pay
service provider who need advanced
notice in order to make the suspensions
on the ability to to not take the um
charge so any changes proposed would
then have to have that cost of changing
with with our supplier but as the report
indicate in the New Year we would be
looking to work with our Economic
Development officer as well and local
business to kind of have a a Forum open
Forum to
ask
them what they would like to support not
we can do everything but just to have
that open conversation because we have
highlighted that this has been kind of
ongoing since 2009 and not been looked
at so I would recommend at this moment
in time we do that and then make further
recommendations for the period from the
New Year onwards and into the next new
Municipal
year thank you Mr B um do you want to
come back on that councilor stanle uh
yes please chairman as this as the from
what has just been said about from
January onwards this is obviously not
the New Year time uh that we're dealing
with and we're only dealing with taking
out one which is the 23rd and replacing
it with the
31st um which I do would believe that
we're not altering the facts or the
figures or anything like that we're just
taking out a day and replacing it so I
just wonder if that if we could consider
that instead of thank
you councilor Stanley are you making an
amendment to The
Proposal uh yes chairman I'd like to
make the amendment of that proposal to
include to to disregard the 23rd and to
include the 31st right members we are
now speaking to the amendment a second
is there a seconder for the amendment
please counc stany there is no seconder
so your proposal
fails the next speaker is Council
Williams thank you chairman um I was
just wonder how successful this this
actually is
by taking away the parking charges
and in fact perhaps it could be
counterproductive in as much that we
then have no I think they call the term
churn and cars can park there all day in
fact they could park there first thing
on a Saturday morning and stay there
until last thing on a Sunday or first
thing on a Sun Monday morning and I just
wonder if perhaps in future this could
be looked at before we make these
decisions thank you thank you councilor
Williams councelor Mr
newort thank you chairman
um just um going on to the report on
page 8.2 3.2 with which states the loss
of income now I'm guessing that or the
clarification on that loss of income is
that up to you know that's not a
certainty is it by any stretch um I
wouldn't want to change to remove that
23rd because I think that will actually
um disadvantage most of the uh men in
who live in the district who do their
Christmas shopping last minute so that
would be my reasoning not for to remove
that date um comical but it probably is
true in a lot of cases so and I really
do welcome
3.3 and I think we do need a cost
benefit analysis on on on and I agree
with councelor Williams you know on on
the effect that this has on the local
economy and uh on our residents and in
fact you know so it does need looking at
in the future but I fully understand the
the that level of
work and the resource requirement for
that level of work so I'm I'm fully
supporting the recommendation in front
of us tonight thank you thank you
councelor Mr newort uh councelor Mrs
Newport thank you I just wanted to ask
you said about the open forum
to engage with businesses and obviously
looking at this much sooner than we are
this year when do you
anticipate looking at it ready for next
year so it's a question through me
to miss bars thank you thank you thank
you chair
um we would be looking to try and P give
us a consultation and meeting with the
businesses in some point in January I
just need to link in with um our
economic officer to help me organize
it thank you thank
you councilor Mrs
Wilson um all my points have been
answered by other members thank you very
much uh particularly uh Mr n's
comment are there any further questions
matters that members wish to
raise if not then we we've heard the
proposal proposed by council Mrs Wilson
seconded
by councel EES thank
you I'll read the recommendation then
put it to the vote recommendation one
that car parking charges in all Council
car parks are suspended on the 2nd 9th
16th and 23rd December
2023 those in favor please show your
hands
as well so it is unanimous thank
you they will be none against for
obvious
reasons
okay thank you we now move to item nine
cost of living Co
payments I would like to ask ask
councelor Mrs Gooding to speak on this I
would ask her not to move the
recommendation I wish to hear what she's
got to say and other members and what
they have to say before considering when
that recommendation should be put thank
you thank you chair the item of business
was referred to the executive bya the
overview and scrutiny committee on the
13th of September 2023
and at its meeting on the 21st of
September
2023 the executive deferred this item to
the next meeting the deferral was
necessary to enable officers to explore
mechanisms for delivery as there was no
criteria in
place we have a recommendation of
deferral before us tonight which I have
holding back at this minute uh however
given the situation with the staff
resources I believe we need to
prioritize this to meet residents needs
sooner rather than later on that basis
with your agreement chair I would
propose a new motion at the appropriate
point when you
advise I didn't get far
members I I'm in your hands as to
whether you ask questions and make
observations at this point or you wish
to hear the motion that Mrs Gooding may
wish to
put I'm in your hands I'll listen to
debate councilor e thank you chair I
believe one of the reasons being why
this was deferred last time was the
criteria was not clear however in 1.3 of
our report here we have a a uh statement
there halfway through the paragraph um
let me read it
uh line four do not automatically meet
the criteria to obtain certain grants
and fund um he let's go back a little
bit further it was concluded that funds
would go towards supporting those who
are struggling with the cost of living
but also those who do do not
automatically meet the criteria to
obtain certain grants that would seem to
indicate that there is a criteria in
place that was the reason being why we
actually deferred it last time so if
there is a criteria in place I don't
understand why it is that we have to
actually defer this again thank
you councilor H you've indicated next to
me that makes it a lot easier yes I
didn't write my name down no um I think
it might be useful for all of the
members of the executive to hear
the motion that Council M Gooding may
put forward tonight first before we
continue because I think that may answer
a number of questions of
members I'll just take a a general
consensus view are we all agreed on that
thank you Council M Gooding would you
like to outline your likely
proposal thank you chair yes the I
propose that the authority is delegated
to the league member for leisure tourism
and well-being and that the director
communities and health to commission a
pro provider through a service level
agreement to provide a grant of £7,000
for Road shows to
assist residents to access support to
help them with the cost of living the
service level agreement will include
conditions including the locations which
is part of the problem that's been
raised the performance measures and the
review of outcomes
thank you
CH I shouldn't really be taking debate
on that at this
point but I would like to ask um Mr
Summers whether against the back ground
of that likely proposal coming forward
what
alternatives
there have been put forward by the
community's
directorate
thank you chair um so you are quite
right it was it's deferred previously in
my understanding is because there was
not the criteria to run a Grant
application process um therefore um we
didn't have the time in detail as
officers to go through and look at
alternative um Solutions or options to
that to that process including that one
as well and identifying that based on
the fact that there was a need for
residents to be having this money and
support as early as possible we did a
high level uh options appraisal which
included um both the council running a
Grant application uh process or an
alternative form run by another provider
in terms of a Grant application process
or alternatively providing the funding
to provider who already does this type
of work who we could um request um with
conditions that they they actually
provide that due to the lack of um
resources that we have internally at the
council to do such grant funding process
um I would say to members that doing
that sort of pro process internally is
very time consuming and takes quite a
lot of effort away from other activities
as well so therefore we did that very
high level piece of work um to
understand the various options and I
think the option that council Mrs good
has come up with tonight is based on the
most beneficial and efficient and
effective way of getting that uh service
out to to Residents thank you chair
thank you Mr Summers members I'm going
to take questions at this point I don't
want opinion don't want views want any
questions on anything you've heard so
far
Council
St thank you chairman um the sum of
7,000 is for the
to
project as a from a road show that's
that's going to how many or where are
these Road shows going to be presented
is it going to be in in Mill or at South
Street or where for this to
happen um and also so how is this uh
there's no mention of how the system is
going to work um in relation to the
hardship fund would that be from
residents that are are already claiming
hardship uh from the council or is this
a separate item all together thank
you Council staning I'm not sure whether
to ask Mr Summers on behalf of the um
communities directorate or counselor Mrs
goody I think I'll ask councelor Mrs
Gooding because um she's got her hands
on the uh the proposed
motion thank you chair so um the service
level agreement will include that
information that you're asking councelor
Stanley so we're already aware that
we've had um the cost of living um event
at the m so we wouldn't want to um
replicate and duplicate the same service
over here when we have a very large
District to cover and we would look to
try and cover other areas to keep um it
across the board for all our residents
um at this time that hasn't been agreed
but through the service level agreement
that will come to fruition but that's
the
idea does that answer all of your
question oh from the sorry um apart from
the the fund itself will that be
available to the families that are in
crisis at the moment and also families
that W will be pertaining to this
fund you willing to
continue um what I would say is similar
to the event that was held at the M Hall
um it is isn't direct funding directly
to families this is the cost of running
the road shows um and any additional
this is my understanding any additional
services but I'm quite happy to hand
over to Steve if if he's got more
information I understand Mr Summers you
you are able to help at this point in
relation to these questions if that
helps chair I think do I think the the
um original report from you and scrutiny
working group uh
concluded um that it would be helpful
for the £7,000 be Mark for the purposes
of Road shows support residents with a
cost of living so I think that's that's
generally where we would be looking for
that to
happen thank you councelor
Stanley councelor Mrs Newport please
this may go through you chair to Steve
um
how quickly will this be available and
we be able to implement
it so ideally we would like to put the
SLA together and uh put that proposal
forward from people who can provide uh
the services we're looking for within
the next two
VES thank you I have councelor Mrs
Wilson uh thank you chair um the
previous uh member asked my first
question so I'm going to go straight to
my second one which was um in the
planning how many Road shows are invis
invis to be run um I'm assuming in the
east of the east of the
district I I can't give you uh a number
at this point because obviously this is
all part of a process with the SLA um
we're looking um to try and do at least
another couple um do you have any
further information to that Mr
suers um no not at this stage I think as
council Mrs goodan has said I think
there's a bit of detail that we need to
work through very quickly I mean
obviously the most we can get from using
the money the bet the better it will be
but by the same token there is a balance
there in providing quality to to
Residents who need it Council
Williams yeah thank you chair I think my
question's been answered actually in in
as much that I'd like confirmation that
the East End of the district will be
treated as reasonably as the West End
and I can confirm to councelor Stanley
that the road shows are very successful
and they to enable the groups that
attend them to help the residents so the
the sooner they they get done really the
better thank you thank you Council
Williams members are there any further
questions members there are no further
questions I'm going to move from the
chair the
recommendation which I need to
[Music]
find no no
no I want to move please because I'm
obliged to move the
recommendation initially for
deferment okay I second that thank okay
as we
must does any member wish to speak to
the proposal which has been
seconded thank
you so where are we indicating um I hav
down yet I also
indicated should I speak first councilor
H yes course yeah perhaps go first
um I'm I think for just for clarity for
people who might may be looking confused
especially members of the public
watching this this is a this the
deferral is on on our paper and we have
to move it whether or not I will vote
for deferral or not is another matter
but I think it we we're bound to do this
and that's why I have seconded the
motion which was put forward by the
chair thank you councelor
Hy Council
Williams my my apologies chair I'm not
sure whether or not as I said at the
beginning
I had a
um a possibility of a um Obin and I
think i' made notice on the wrong item I
won't vote anymore on this one because
ravs May well be one of the people that
that help in this situation that that
can be minuted thank you very much for
declaring it at this
point are there any further indications
from
Members right I will put the
recommendation is
printed and then I'll call for a vote
the recommendation which has been
seconded by councilor
Hoy the recommendation R1 is that the
appended report be deferred to the
executive on the 16th of November
2023 due to staff
absences I'm going to ask for those who
are in favor of the recommendation to
show their hands
please
there are
none I'd like members to show their
hands for those who are against the
recommendation
please for those that can vote that is
unanimous I'm now going to ask councelor
Mrs Gooding to
put the motion that she has indicated is
available
able thank you chair so the motion is
that the authority is delegated to the
lead member for leisure tourism and
wellbe and the director communities and
health to commission a provider through
a service level agreement to provide a
grant of
£7,000 for Road shows to assist
residents to access support to help them
with the cost of living the service
level agreement is to include conditions
including the locations the performance
measures and a review of
outcomes thank you you do I have a
seconder please I'll be seconding thank
you chairman second counselor councelor
ho councelor Crips you're indicating for
what oh okay thank you it's nice to see
people clamoring to to Second motions
thank you right I'll now take speakers
who wish to um speak to the motion
please
councelor Mr
newo thank you chairman um I think you
know it
was I think I'm I'd just like to put on
record really that I'm really thankful
for um the lead member and their
tenacious approach to trying to resolve
this issue um don't think any of us
wanted to defer this motion and you know
we want to do the best for our residents
with the cost of living so I think we
did need that time to explore I think
that's that's good and uh hopefully now
that members will support this motion
thank
you anybody else wish to speak I would
Mike councelor H yeah I i' just very
brief to say thank you very much for
counselor Mrs Gooding for putting
together that motion which I think saves
a lot of embarrassment from the from
this executive I'd also like to thank um
councelor J mcferson for putting the
report together in the first place from
the oness committee and I'm pleased with
that we can move forward with it now
without any
further major delays thank
you speaking for myself and not as chair
I'd like to also thank councelor Mrs
Gooding I'd like to thank councelor
mcferson and the on committee also for
bringing forward the report in good time
and in the appro with the appropriate
recommendations I also like to thank um
Mr Summers and his team for all the
support I've received today and Council
Gooding has received today to enable
this um reconsideration to take place
today and not later so thank you very
much to all of you that concludes the
speakers I believe in which case I shall
now put the motion to the vote councelor
Mrs Gooding would you read that that
once again thank
[Music]
you thank you the motion is that the
authority is delegated to the lead
member for leisure tourism and
well-being and the director communities
and health to commission a provider
through a service level agreement to
provide a grant of £7,000 for Road shows
to assist residents to access support to
help them with the cost of living the
service level agreement is to include
conditions including locations
performance measures and a review of
outcomes as seconded by councilor Hoy I
now ask members for a show of hands of
those in favor of the
motion and myself thank
you Council Williams you've um stepped
out of the voting thank you so that was
unanimous I don't need to take any
further votes
now I can't find the
agenda I can find
it right item nine has concluded the
business um for this executive meeting
and I thank you and thank the visiting
members and members of the public for
attending and I'll close this meeting at
819 thank you very
much